[Music]
and welcome back to off the record where
we talk about whatever we want now now
i'm desensitizing i don't know if it's
whatever we want not really some of the
things that we want to change this [ __ ]
because it's kind of like whatever we
want as long as we won't get canceled
for it yeah whatever is careful boys
welcome to the camp welcome careful boys
what is this segment careful boys
whatever no news it's just like off the
cuff shift we just talk [ __ ] okay okay
we came up with it because like
you know we used to do just all news but
then sometimes we just like to talk yeah
so it's like podcast style talk some
[ __ ] it's been a while since you were
here yeah it's been a long time yeah
yeah since then you've been like a wu
assassin
was that are you a wood what's the last
thing you did i guess so does that make
you is that what it is is that like the
right term assassin well i'm not the woo
assassin but you know i'm part of this
crew
you're like entourage i'm like entourage
of louis like johnny drama of the wu
assassins yeah
yeah nice yeah that's awesome
it's a it's a tv show that we're hoping
like asians would galvanize behind and
support in order to continue to progress
like asian media and stuff but
i see you didn't support it
i definitely didn't know about it watch
it it's on netflix
man if you don't have a stop asian hay
sticker on the back of your car you're
not my friend
you need to get a sticker asap i know
i'll get the sticker guys
i need to know that you're a [ __ ]
ally dude dude come on man
i'm down for performative too like i
just need to see it yeah we need to see
that i got you covered though that needs
to be in your instagram bio with a
hashtag
with my pronoun tonight dude yeah dude
it's like
[Laughter]
that's a good start was that was that
the uh last thing before the pandemic
that you were pretty much a regular on
or
uh the wheel assassins
did you shoot in the movie yeah
yeah during the pandemic we shot in
thailand so we're just like you shot the
tv show and the movie no the tv show was
before the pandemic oh so we shot there
i think it was way before right yeah
yeah i was like but it came out like
2019 too 2019. yeah yeah yeah
so how was shooting in thailand man it
was awesome man it's [ __ ] cool
everything's on location so it's not
like we're shooting like on built sets
it's just like we're like at actual
temples wow yeah it was cool man what's
the crazy [ __ ] you're allowed to a
careful boy say on this
that you did in thailand yeah
thailand
boys careful
so like everything was like pretty much
open when we were there like legs
covid was very low there was like no
kobets so like everything was so like we
would go out we would go out like you
know we could go to clubs and stuff and
it was just so different than you know
here no masks no masks people were just
walking around but you know what's funny
is like right when i left like
immediately they had they got like huge
cases
because you spread it all
and
and
so like the people that we were hanging
out with right
the people that we were hanging out with
um
you know they're in the entertainment
industry and stuff they were on the
newspaper for being like um the people
that like these are the people that were
spreading covet oh
it was crazy too because we were hanging
out with those those guys too at the
time and this is like like we just left
and it was just like pretty insane
was it a group full of americans and
they're like these [ __ ] came to
thailand and spread cove everywhere
they're from thai yeah did we get
executed afterwards no no no were they
close
was the country closed closed
no you could at that time you could go
and then you just would have to
quarantine was it early coved
this was in january this january oh
[ __ ] this year
damn
so we were there for like three months
and it was fun man it's just like you
know have you guys been to thailand yeah
never it's crazy the food is like
insane out of this world it's like
everything
it's stronger
tastes better like there's a pad thai
out there
it's good
it's good it's like on the street but
like just like just tasting like chicken
like it just tastes different the
ingredients or something yeah
ingredients like all the produce and
stuff it's just better
was it like very pungent to you like
this some of the like even rice smell
like [ __ ] like fish sauce or
something like it was strong yeah
everything just has a you know yeah just
tastes better
aromatic aromatic is it thai spicy
everything kind of spicy
um
yeah stuff is pretty spicy you would
just probably have to get stuff that's
like
mild or no spice at all i got a lot of
non spices i like spices on everything
the boat noodles are real good
yup did you uh did you uh
be careful when you admit to this
did you ride little elephants or hold
baby tigers ah no no unfortunately not i
hugged that man we weren't able to i
wish i could do that you pick up a baby
dolphin and take a picture with it
how about a snake nobody gives a [ __ ]
about snakes yeah yeah i had a big
python around my neck
no one yet nobody gets mad at you for
holding snakes around is it because your
shooting schedule is nuts you didn't
have time to have like yeah we couldn't
really like go to islands and stuff what
was your shooting schedule like eight
hour days 12 hour days um
[Music]
it's like 8 to 12 hour days i believe
you're just using
[Laughter]
it's been over 20 years since i've been
there oh yeah yeah
like i feel like i mean i haven't been
i've never been before so like i feel
like it's usually like
there's like a lot of tourists and stuff
so i feel like it was cool when we went
because there was just like no one there
wow just got to like roam around and it
was just it's a lot of fun that's on my
must-go list for sure thailand
and we were trained at this guy's um um
satyan's gym he's like a popular muay
thai uh trainer out in in thailand so it
was cool to just like
train there what was the coach's name
uh satyan
never heard him got this guy dude he
wasn't listening are you a fighter yeah
i follow a bunch of thai guys
not that guy not that guy
so you got like muay thai training out
there i did thailand i didn't i was just
i was just learning like uh like the
choreography and stuff that i needed to
do for the movie but then um yeah other
people were like going in and getting
rounds in people that were like already
like you know
that have muay thai in them that that
already know how to do it and they were
like getting rounds in and practicing
and stuff so it was cool to watch and
stuff i should have like
taken advantage of it but i am a little
boy that doesn't want to get hurt and uh
no you're just like a small man it's not
a small man did you get hurt doing this
because you're doing action [ __ ] right
you know it's like i didn't get hurt but
what was funny was like i was out i was
at a club towards the end of the shoot
and then i i had jumped off a
i was going up a stage to go to like a
vip area and and um
when you go up the first side of the
stage there were no stairs right so i
like hopped on i was like okay but when
i hopped off i was assuming that there
were no stairs on the other side
so i jumped off and there was like
these stairs on the bottom and i just
[ __ ] my ankle just out oh my god and
i had one more week of like shooting
what so you did it on a rolled ankle
yeah i couldn't i couldn't step on this
ankle but what was funny was before i
went to the club the the week before the
scene was at i got
spoiler alert i get stabbed in that leg
perfect it was like perfect so the next
week i was just like broken you know
when you fell what was the scream that
you let up yeah it [ __ ] hurts but i
was drunk and i was like
i was like i went up to um i went into
my castle and i was like dude i messed
up my ankle and then it's it's it's
[ __ ] and then we just kept going we
just hung out
oh dudes the next morning it was like it
was back it's stiffened up and [ __ ] it
was bad swollen did you elevate it yeah
okay good
that's the only question i had did you
elevate it what does satyan do about it
[Laughter]
make it stronger
did he put tiger bomb on it
i get this from america
there's got some thai [ __ ] you can use
like
i
how long were you there for uh january
till the end of march that's a long time
yeah
i don't know if we're allowed to go
there right now i don't think we're
allowed to go right now you got to be
like a hollywood actor you know
on a work permit an essential worker
yeah actually you might be able to
actually
you just have to quarantine places that
don't allow oh yeah that's right i think
they were doing a thing where like they
allowed people to come and then
quarantine on boats
that's cool
because we japanese can come to the
states but we can't go to japan
oh really that's fair yeah but japanese
can't go to japan no they could japanese
can come to the states but then the u.s
citizens oh i see
but like uh they just lifted the travel
ban
for europe and uk uh in november oh
really so they could travel they're
about to listen to that yeah and then so
that means we can go back we can go
there we've always been able to go there
oh they couldn't come here here so it's
weird yes weird rules like that
yeah we've been
able to go follow the money yep follow
the money the paper trail man what the
hell the perpetrator what the hell man
when does the movie come out uh we don't
know yet i think either december or
january
is called wu assassins it's called
fistful of vengeance oh sorry that's a
tight title continuation
movie of the series what we're trying to
do is like try to make a movie and
people like it then we'll make another
movie after that sort of like a semi
wu assassins franchise today's video is
brought to you by curology so i've been
using curology now for
over two years
um and it's been pretty cool because
you know i waited till my 30s to
actually get into skin care i never did
it in my 20s and i don't think soap even
touched this face in my teens really
dude i i just rinsed with water i never
i don't know maybe maybe the shampoo
that i was washing my hair with dripped
into my forehead but then
i thought i brushed my teeth i used the
toothpaste
[Laughter]
but what's cool is that
one of the reasons why i didn't get into
it is because it was so complicated yeah
and i don't know i just never really
wanted to sit there and research and
figure out and i didn't i never had a
feeling of like i want to make this
better you know yeah what do you do go
down the skin care aisle there's all
kinds of
chemicals you're like i don't know what
this does what's this what's salicylic
acid and there's all these things you're
like what am i supposed to take it's
super overwhelming it's super
overwhelming and that's why curology is
so cool because they have a licensed
dermatology provider help you custom
formulate things to whatever your goals
are so if you have acne or you got dark
spots that you want to get rid of they
can help you formulate something that's
unique to you and they also have all
kinds of products so they have body wash
they got emergency spot patches like
you're trying to go to prom you got an
interview and you got a big old zit over
here just put on top of it and help it
go away and it's super simple so you
just go on their site fill out the
survey of what your skin goals are and
then they come out with the formula and
for me i have a face wash so i can just
wash it in the shower right quick and
then there is my special formula and
then there is a uh
moisturizer that i use too to moisturize
so
pretty cool so yeah if you want to take
your skin care to the next level go to
curology.com
off the record to unlock your free
30-day trial in one month you can see a
huge difference with your skin all you
have to do is pay for shipping and
handling that's curology.com
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y.com
off the record to unlock your free
30-day trial all you have to do is pay
for shipping and handling thank you very
much do you guys go like when you guys
are brainstorming you're like all right
this has to do better numbers than
shanxi we gotta like
[Laughter]
[ __ ] cheaters
they're like yeah
i mean we definitely have the desire to
be like yeah we want a lot of people to
watch it because if no one watches it
we're not gonna maybe be able to make it
like each one of these movies have a lot
of pressure you know you do like crazy
rich asians i'm sure the shane team's
like oh we gotta at least get somewhere
near that level in each movie i saw a
crazy rich asian slot machine at the
casino and i was like wow they really
made it at the binions oh bro that you
made it it's over there they got
licensing deals all the way to the slot
machines lot machines with crazy rich
asians yeah and i saw it in a couple of
casinos
dude i [ __ ] love
slot machines like themes and [ __ ] yeah
i love that [ __ ] i don't place lots at
all but i love looking at that [ __ ]
really
what intrigues you about it it's just it
just reminds me being a kid and like
like a kid in chuck e cheese like
bejeweled and [ __ ] dude i like the one
where there's like a poker chick that
she's a dealer but even as a cartoon she
has big titties yeah yeah they can't
stop jiggling around they still jiggle
yeah no matter what and she's like
dealing with cards
and still jiggling i'm like even the
animator really got this down
remember that fighting game dead or
alive yeah for like dreamcast or
whatever it was like the jiggliest game
ever made no way they could ever fight
in those outfits no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way dude just have nipples
everywhere oh actually all fighting
games i only played tomb raider for one
reason
aren't there like cheat codes where you
can make them naked and stuff bro right
there's videos of lara croft getting
[ __ ] by monsters up
don't even sweat it it's called good fan
art hey don't trip bro i got some videos
don't even worry about it
[ __ ] limb around his dick have you
ever seen gi joe going a tent
and the tent's just shaking i got those
kind of dude gi joe [ __ ] king cobra
bro
i got you covered bro you see snake eyes
versus king kong
yeah my point collection is sick
all
right well yeah it's careful boy so i
can't even talk about it no yeah you
can't talk about how you play [ __ ]
x-men if you wish wolverine's pants
would fly off
you didn't got adamantium dick
that's a really dumb question
but of course he would but there's no
bone in there oh that's true that's
adamantium bones dude yeah but what out
when he gets a boner
it's just blood that's the stupidest
apologize it could be liquid metal it
could be yeah well you better this is is
his blood like
i don't know the the world that that
well like is the blood with the music
i really don't they're called mutants
okay mutants sorry animantium okay is
that his blood
steel
are you larping right now you don't know
[ __ ] wolverine facts
i just know i know wolverine has the
three things that come out it's hannah
you know the wolverines i do you don't
know but he did a super healing and [ __ ]
okay now i know that i know hey come on
come on he's back we're gonna break him
live forever does he live forever he
doesn't live forever doesn't he die he's
a [ __ ] jellyfish jeans [ __ ] no he
doesn't die dude no he's got jellyfish
coming back the only way he dies of his
head gets separated you got stuck on a i
think hulk didn't ever find it
killed him yeah
why did he die hulk ripped him in half
yeah that's the only way like if you
separate the head and the spine from the
body that's the only way
so he died
well no he actually chucked him like to
africa or something and then wolverine
actually crawled back to his body really
yeah it was [ __ ] crazy
africa yeah there so he [ __ ] swam in
south america he chucked him all the way
yeah he chucked him out he swam over the
atlantic yeah i think so facts y'all are
you sure dude i remember this [ __ ]
no wolverine crawls back to i remember
he crawled back to his body no hulk
threw him into the sun
no no it looked like he was dead though
for sure it's all myth huh create your
own story but there's so many storylines
yeah when i google does wolverine die uh
the first thing it talks about is uh
before he dies from suffocation from
hardening adamantium what kneeling in
the sunset outside of dr cornelius's
base what about hulk kills wolverine all
right there's a storyline like that yeah
yeah he gets thrown away he rips him
rips him in half chucks from africa
i mean he threw him from south america
like he's like in brazil or some [ __ ]
yeah he [ __ ] played with all tosses
you're fighting
all right the first thing that comes up
listening to the story i thought they
were friends first thing that comes out
says marvel settled the wolverine versus
hulk in the most disgusting way the hulk
severely underestimated wolverine's
abilities and thought he could eat him
alive but killing wolverine is
practically impossible even if he's
devoured into little bits in this fight
wolverine was a decisive win against
hole giving him his most disgusting
victory
of the gown so yeah hulk ate wolverine
he pooped him out to south america and
then wolverine slowly rebuilt himself
from the ship pile
yeah this one says uh did the hulk eat
wolverine ripping wolverine in half is
brutal enough as the hook is done but
eating that beloved x member is a bridge
too far when he finished slicing up the
hulk's children old man logan finally
got to the giant and stabbed him with
his animatronics dude what why is it so
personal dude he sliced his children
what hulk got kids holy [ __ ] wait why
why do they have beef in the fridge
because like because he sliced up his
kids yeah so wolverine killed hulk's
kids that's what it said
it's actually crazy i thought they were
both good guys yo comics are wild but
good guys can become bad guys too right
we had this conversation because you
know in the walking dead and the bad
they changed yeah they changed
the comics in the walking dead is even
crazier oh yeah yeah yeah you didn't do
any study of your your characters
there's just there's they do blow jobs
and stuff too
that's why you brought the [ __ ] here
last time no he brought the blow jobs
but there's blow jobs i think [ __ ]
get brought up in every article no but
they're they're doing uh blow jobs in
the prison and stuff remember when they
were like in the prison like all that
what does that have to do with the story
with the progression of the ark and all
that
nature it's human nature you know you
need the
release yeah two different zombies again
all oh
oh dude that's like a frog with a fifi
bag oh my god monkey frog no no there is
but then the the comics always are
crazier than the tv show because of
censorship yeah we can't have their
zombies around i don't think [ __ ]
are going to stick around you know
there's no censorship for comics right
what i don't think so dog's gonna be a
thing well dude think about it and
walking down i always think about this
too because i'm like kind of a clean
freak like when it comes to sex stuff
like dude walking dead that's so dirty
and things like they're [ __ ] and
stuff i'm like dude they don't got
showers i don't have running water they
used to be just people right they're
like yeah you're saying the zombies are
[ __ ] and walking dead no no like
you're just saying it's dirty in that
it's dirty like you're camping and then
you're just like a caveman isn't that
like where we all came from in general
yeah but do you think caveman and cave
women were like blowing each other all
the time i think that's why [ __ ] gets
so wet
cleaning it yeah exactly oh
soft cleaning system
it really
yeah all right
that's what pre-cum is for doug we're
doctors what about the outside yeah and
lawrence i don't know if you know this
but all of us here
are you coming here
google wolverine crawling from africa to
south america
to reattach you could probably bring it
on the [ __ ] too clean it up
it is sterile
so what did what does that mean if it's
sterile what does that mean what do
people do when there's packages in there
you dummy
okay so yeah so oh so it just means that
it's just like there's nothing bad in it
yeah so i won't keep you know it doesn't
have healing properly shower like once a
month people used to only shower like
once a month because they thought it
would make them sick so they're still
[ __ ] every day though yep but you
think blow jobs were the thing though
like it was that it was like rampant i
seen when what year
i seen i seen greek i i seen greek
pottery with [ __ ] a girl being a a
like a turkey rotisserie chicken and
she's getting [ __ ] and sucking on
a dick but they were cleaner though yeah
they did take group baths mediterranean
peoples yeah like they were never dirty
and [ __ ] even in game of thrones when
they would go take the mediterranean
demigods
how about this like back in the day in
las vegas they had the that the bravos
they didn't have showers oh like the
western times people even recently when
people were building the boulder dam and
[ __ ] like they came in [ __ ] with all
this uh concrete grease on their body
and their [ __ ] i don't even think we
need to go back in history or to
post-apocalyptic non-fiction or fiction
to think like dirty [ __ ] happens
every day dude i seen pottery in las
vegas of a girl just getting [ __ ]
holding two dicks
classic
they built vegas in the 60s i think
right here the 50s yeah
it's crazy at all times they were just
going yeah they're going out
dirty sex happens all the time after the
bar
or camping camping camping camping for
sure very dirty homeless people [ __ ]
like crazy too they sure do
we're psychologists too man
let me just have you back there because
we're careful boys they're the unhomed
yeah
i'm howls
we can't call them homeless no more the
unhoused they're [ __ ] unhoused can
you call them homies is that weird
is that wrong are they your friends they
kind of are
if they're your homies then yeah if
they're your homie are we not all
brothers and sisters under the sun i
guess we can call them brothers
and sisters
dude i was at a party one time and this
guy was drunk as [ __ ] and we were like
carrying them out i'm like i got you
brother and he's like i'm not your
[ __ ] brother you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
so you dropped them right i mean yeah so
you beat his ass this is one of those
things where i'm already holding him and
i'm just like i got you brother don't
you ever cover that piece of [ __ ] he was
like any vomits
maybe maybe he's like an only child and
like him having a brother was like so
like it's a big deal yeah i'm an only
child you know and if someone call
actually i don't care about the brother
thing but like i mean i could see like
maybe if i really really wanted a
brother and then it just never [ __ ]
happened and then like someone's like
yeah you're my brother i never had a
brother [ __ ] you you're resentful
i think he's just an angry drunk but
maybe not
surprised he's angry drunk
you